- Do you all think of this?
Have you,
I know that you had heard of Thistle Farms
Allison but have you
ever heard of Thistle Farms?
- I've been,
drugs and alcohol free for about 22 years,
and I've been,
I have a been a different
program a little bit.
(audience clapping)
- Yeah.
But it was a,
it was somebody of a different sort
who reached out to me.
It was so many years ago,
and not even in my position
which is very different.
But because I had money,
and I was a star,
people helped,
they enable you to get by.
- [Kelly] Mm-hmm (affirmative)
And I heard what you said,
the program I practiced it's all about,
as soon you get it,
you gotta give it away.
- Absolutely.
- You can't,
a kid can't hold on to all these toys
and every time he sees a new toy he goes,
"Mine."
(laughs)
Because you gonna drop one those
before I give can you another one.
- Yeah.
- So what is important that she said is,
it really resonated with me is it,
you get it?
It doesn't happen overnight.
It's a day to day thing.
You gotta reprise every day.
But I said,
giving back what somebody gives you,
that's,
I see this happen right here.
This is a miracle and I see
- Yeah.
it in my particular program,
I see it all the time.
- Well,
and also the way you're saying though is,
you are amazing Becca for
providing this opportunity
for people and that person is amazing for,
shining a light on it and go,
"Hey, there's a problem."
But at the same time,
you have to be willing to receive it.
- Mm-hmm (affirmative)
- [Kelly] You have to be
willing to engage and you,
you have to be able to change your life.
Somebody can't do that for you.
So that's the amazing part as well.
And I'm so excited to meet you
- Yeah.
- and so proud of you,
you're graduating soon.
- Thank you.
- In two months,
that's exciting
(handclaps)